les cinq heures zenjov qui subissait un
procès pour meurtre à la suite de la
méga opération chaque c'est un 2009
cette opération
on était tous remis en liberté
aujourd'hui en fait julie marceau leur
procès est carrément annulé ils sont
libres voilà et c'est une victoire
entière pour la défense qui réclamait
l'arrêt des procédures donc ils vont
tanguay claude berger les frères sylvain
et françois vachon est ce que michel
vallières qui sont aujourd'hui des
hommes libres pourquoi l'arrêt des
procédures
l'opération sharqc a débuté en 2009 156
personnes arrêtées et donc ces cinq
personnes qui se retrouvent libres
aujourd'hui c'est en raison patrice
d'une question de divulgation de la
preuve communication d'éléments de
preuves qui ont été faites trop
tardivement selon les juges de la cour
supérieure qui a rendu sa décision
aujourd'hui je vais vous en lire un
extrait le juge brunton qui dit la
communication tardive des éléments
preuve faisait sciemment partie d'un
désir de gagner à tout prix les temps à
adopter une conduite choquant le sens du
franc jeu donc la continuation de ce
procès malgré l'importance de la
criminalité alléguées seraient
préjudiciables à l'intégrité du système
de justice
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que ces
éléments de preuve était réclamée par la
défense depuis 2011
elle les a obtenues qu'en 2015 durant le
procès et c'était des éléments cruciaux
qui aurait pu par exemple remettre en
doute en question la crédibilité d'un
témoin vedette qui est au coeur de cette
affaire donc requête de la défense
accueilli la défense qui était
évidemment bien heureuse ce que l'on
considère toutes et chacune d'entre nous
sait que c'est vraiment justice a été
rendue aujourd'hui c'était nous
une décision très importante mais
justice en est grandement grandis tu es
des gens qui attendent depuis 2009
justement qui ont trait confiance à ce
que justice soit rendue et ils sont très
heureux bien entendu pouvoir avoir leur
famille surtout et à prendre leur vie en
main
ils ont persévéré en étant convaincu
qu'il y avait des lacunes
bon est-ce que la poursuite pardon qui a
une très dure journée avec cette
décision-là absolue et ce qu'elle
pourrait aller en appel
alors oui mais elle doit prouver qu'il
ya eu erreur dans une question de droit
donc elle a 30 jours pour analyser
justement le jugement
donc voici là dessus le dpcp au
directeur des poursuites criminelles et
pénales va prendre le temps d'analyser
la décision d'évaluer les options qui
s'offraient au directeur des poursuites
criminelles et pénales afin de voir si
le lieu d'interjeter appel de cette
décision
pas très juste pour vous faire le
décompte on parlait opération 2009 156
personnes arrêtées là dessus pour bien
comprendre 104 ont plaidé coupables 38
ont été libérés neuf personnes sont
toujours recherchées trois décédés ce
qu'il reste de ce méga procès et de
l'opération chaque amorcé en 2009
aujourd'hui à 7 heures ce sont deux
co-accusés anglophones qui vont subir
leur procès en anglais en 2017 alors les
mégaprocès
or ont avorté avant le début voila voila
merci je vous en prie